un sonido
reconocible desde las primeras notas
Jeff Beck sabía hacer sonar las cuerdas
de su guitarra eléctrica Como nadie
desde el anuncio de su muerte se
multiplican los homenajes de sus
compañeros No puedo expresar la tristeza
que siento al enterarme del
fallecimiento de Jeff Beck qué terrible
pérdida para su familia amigos y muchos
aficionados fue un honor haberle
conocido y que tocara en mi último disco
Jeff Beck creció en el sur de Londres y
se convirtió en una sensación en los
años 60 con su banda de
una cuna de talento que vio crecer a
otros dos Héroes de la guitarra Erick
Clapton y Jimmy page que más tarde se
convirtió en el guitarrista de Led
Zeppelin su técnica única su imaginación
Aparentemente ilimitada Jeff te echaré
de menos a ti y a tus millones de fans
descansa en paz a principios de los 70
Beck inició una carrera en solitario
mezclando géneros Rock jazz blues
con su discreta personalidad El músico
británico pasó como un desconocido para
una parte del Gran público pero sus
colegas lo han puesto en el panteón de
los guitarristas en un quinto lugar
según la revista Rolling Stone junto a
un tal Jimi Hendrix
el verano pasado estuvo marcado por su
colaboración con Johnny Depp la historia
de una amistad improbable que pocos
habrían imaginado hace unos años
llamaron a mi puerta y me dijeron que
Johnny
no lo conocía sabía que había
interpretado a Jack Sparrow Aunque nunca
había visto esas películas Tuvimos una
buena charla y así ha sido Durante los
últimos seis años
un último homenaje el de una leyenda del
rock británico mick jagger con este
vídeo de dos viejos amigos se tentones
divirtiéndose como en los viejos tiempos
[Música]